this footage aired on Iranian State
television for pots to show damage to a
military facility near the Central City
of Isfahan it also broadcast the debris
of what it called bomb carrying drones
the defense Ministry says at least one
was intercepted and shot down Tehran
blames Israel for the attack
this cowardly attack was carried out
against us our security bodies are
powerfully acting to ensure maximum
National Security and such moves can't
impact our nuclear scientists will and
intentions to achieve peaceful nuclear
energy
several incidents have been reported at
Iranian military facilities in recent
years including a fire and a blackout
although it provides few details Tehran
blames Israel and describes them as
targeted attacks
Iran is facing criticism on several
fronts at the moment the West has
condemned it for supplying Russia with
weapons for the war in Ukraine
uranium enrichment has resumed as stocks
to revive the nuclear deal have been
stalled since September
and have been months of anti-government
protests following the death of a young
woman in police custody it does
nevertheless achieved several Israeli
objectives the first one being that
Israel is under increasing pressure to
side with Ukraine against Russia the
Israelis have for almost a year now held
out uh seeking to avoid taking sides
because of their own vulnerability to
Russia and this strike enables Israelis
to make the argument that yes they're
not providing weapons to the ukrainians
but instead they are targeting Iran who
has been supporting Russia
Isfahan is about 440 kilometers from
Tehran it houses a large air base and
several nuclear energy research and
production sites among them Nathans
which is at the center of Iran's nuclear
development program
Sharif Al Jazeera